okay well now you gave me another idea
okay so let's say i'm walking along
the beach yeah and i'm looking at the
waves and the sand and the sun am i
supposed to feel
or is it good for me to feel connected
to it and feel as if the waves are alive
in some manner and i'm speaking to the
rocks because in the dead end
left hemispheric view i see them or
one would see them as impressions
picturesque impressions upon my
slate of sense so sense data pressed
upon me
but then i can and then i know that
that's associated with schizophrenia
schizophrenic ideation in its extreme
okay but then in the other extreme i
could see someone going and talking to
the rocks
and and holding them up and kissing them
as that its own form of
psychosis but i'm not sure i don't know
if that's actually associated with
schizophrenic
thought either way i want to hear so
which one should i do should i
stand back passively of you or should i
treat it somehow emulated in my brain as
this is living
be curt be in this world as if you're
living
engaging with it but these are not just
plastic objects that of wood
they're they're also not beings let's
say
but they're there's something to them
there's some life that they have
so how how does one dance that web
because i can see
inane craziness on both ends of the
spectrum
but does it have to be one or the other
in keeping with what i've been saying
isn't it an error to go to one extreme
of either of these not because the
reality exists in a compromise
but because there is a wholly different
position that is only found when you
reconcile the two opposites
that is my point um and it's imaged in
that
taut string um but
i think it's a very unusual view we have
of
the world that we are separate from it
and it is dead
and that any life in it is something we
attribute to it
i argue and it's too long an argument to
do now
i even argue that inanimacy
is if you like the ultimate limit case
of animacy
not that animus here's some weird thing
that popped into the cosmos
i think animacy is of the essence
of a conscious universe in different
ways in different degrees
animals and animosity or are the union
animals no no as
as as in things being animated so
obviously yes um but
we don't have to to go to to to that
that extr
well not an extreme but but to that
length if you like
um we i wouldn't have time to justify
that position but i think i do in my
book
but in any case most people at most
times in the world
have not failed to make a proper
scientific assessment and
come up with a theory that things around
them are alive
they know they're alive because they
actually experience
that and we have told ourselves that we
can't be experiencing that because
it's just not wrong isn't it i mean an
age of science
but what do we know about that actually
science is not dealing with that
question science is not
able to talk about whether there is
um something that has
consciousness or animacy in the world
outside
of our own heads so
i don't think that one needs to either
tell oneself what's wrong when one feels
a sense of connectedness
or think that being properly connected
means
you're being being swallowed up and you
don't you know love those waves so much
that you go into a rough scene and get
drowned
so you need to keep walking this
balance and it's all about the balance
or harmony harmony was the greek word
and it's a word that we've lost because
i mean our world has so little harmony
in it
um things that we call harmony are
actually
dictated fiats that things must be like
this
but no true harmony is is a kind of
thing that has to evolve
between things being fully themselves
and not pretending to be something
they're not
so yeah i think it i think it is a very
very
important element